if you rotate a ball around one axis then another it's not the same as doing the two rotations in the reverse order
today in kiss in the classroom we'll see what this ball has to do with quantum computers and one of the most famous
principles of quantum mechanics the uncertainty
principle welcome to kissk in the classroom a video series where we break down a fundamental concept that you
might encounter in a Quantum Computing related course each video is accompanied by an interactive module Linked In the
description below so be sure to check that out today we're talking about the Heisenberg uncertainty principle if
you've heard about it before you may have also heard the old joke about Heisenberg one day he was pulled over while driving and the cop asked him do
you know how fast you were going Heisenberg responded no but I know exactly where I am this is kind of
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle in a nutshell you can't simultaneously know about a particle's position and momentum
with perfect Precision it's often written like this Delta x * Delta p is greater than
or equal to h/ 2 where Delta X and Delta P are the
uncertainties in the position and momentum and H is a tiny fundamental constant in quantum mechanics
Heisenberg came up with this inequality back in 1927 when he was imagining how to measure the position of an electron if
you bounced a photon off of it to see where it is that Photon would inevitably kick the electron and disturb its
momentum this isn't just a statement about measurements disturbing a system it tells us that there are fundamental
limits to how much we can learn about nature this is one example of a broader principle called complimentarity which
says that certain aspects of nature are incompatible with one another and can't be observed
simultaneously for example Quantum objects sometimes behave like their particles and sometimes like their waves
but you can't observe both behaviors simultaneously Heisenberg's position and momentum relation covered just one of
many sets of complementary features this inherent uncertainty has to do with how we View Property like
position and momentum in quantum mechanics instead of thinking of X and P as variables or intrinsic properties
that each particle possesses in quantum mechanics position and momentum are operators they're not properties of a
system but things you can do to a system learning about a particle's position now requires you to perform an
operation on that system and make a measurement this operation could affect the outcome of other subsequent
operations as an analogy think about a piece of dry wood it has many properties like its
position size shape it also has the property of being burnable and being floatable in water if this wood were a
Quantum object these wouldn't be properties that you could just know a priority instead we say they're
observables things you can learn about the system if you perform some operation on it so you would need to apply burn
burnability or floatability operators which would require actually trying to burn the wood or putting it in
water to see if it floats now the outcome of each of these operators depends on the order you apply them if
you first test burnability the wood will burn to Ash and you won't be able to test to see if it floats but if you test
floatability first then it'll be too wet to burn we say that the burnability and
floatability operators don't don't commute the order of operations matters this leads to a fundamental
limit to how well these two observables can be known about the piece of wood since we can't say for sure whether it's
burnable or floatable without knowing the context of that measurement now of course with an actual piece of wood you
could cut it in half and test both those properties simultaneously but you can't do anything like that with a Quantum particle this
analogy to Wood is is just that an analogy uncertainty is a uniquely Quantum thing X and P also don't commute
and this property of non-c commuity is what leads to Heisenberg's uncertainty principle in general any two operators
that don't commute will have their own uncertainty principle the general form of the uncertainty principle can be
written like this Delta a * Delta
B is greater than or equal to
12 time there's a and b where
this bracket is called the
commutator and that's equal to the difference between applying first a then
B and applying first B then a these angle brackets
here signal that you're taking What's called the expectation value of what's inside basically if you made the same
measurement many many times the expectation value is the average value of all those measurements today we're
going to actually test and verify this uncertainty principle on an IBM quantum computer we'll look at three different
observables of a cubit show that their operators don't commute and then finally we'll be able to prove that the
uncertainty principle holds holds for these Cubit observables first a brief aside about a helpful way to visualize the quantum
state of a cubit it can be represented by a vector pointing to some place on a sphere called The Block sphere I covered
this in a previous video which is linked in the description but I'll just give you a quick recap here too here's the
block sphere each Vector is parameterized by two angles Theta and F
the state zero is on the North pole and the state one is on the South Pole and an equal superposition of 0 and one is
somewhere along the Equator where f is equal to the relative phase between the two parts of the
superposition so this state here would be equal
to 1 / < tk2 0 + e to the I 1 where I is that
phase when we measure an observable of the Cubit the result is always one of two options corresponding to the two
possible states of the Cubit for the experiment we're about to do we'll look at three observables and
their corresponding operators X Y and Z when you measure any of these observables you get either plus one or
minus one with a probability for each that depends on the angle between the cubit's vector on the Block sphere and